[Musique]
oui mais parle d'un comme si c'est
seulement lundi puis cette semaine je
pense que je suis comme beaucoup de gens
les deux yeux tournés à l'extérieur du
pays à l'extérieur justement des
relations qui existent en tic et des
ailes comme nous détectons je me tourne
vers ce qui se passe en ukraine va
justement l'invasion de la russie dans
un pays qui n'est pas le mien qui
culturellement je n'ai aucune relation
avec lui à pendre une relation qui s'est
pourra aussi sur le territoire canadien
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je voulais
partager l'histoire un peu du coup
comscore qui est une histoire qui est un
peu je devrais partagé par beaucoup de
programmation canada parce que le cocoon
score et souvent donc aucune pour
grand-maman scorff pour le floor donc
c'est le flirt avec la mer mais c'est
aussi à ce qu'on appelle le babouche
cosco est fou le fouloir de babouche là
parce que c'était des flores d'origine
ukrainienne et on se demande bien
comment c'est arrivé dans les
communautés pourquoi est ce que les
femmes dans les parents portent un
surcoût que les hommes le porte un
bandeau c'est un motif très flou rennes
qui justement est un peu en entier mais
c'est que dans la moitié du 19e siècle
les communautés chrétiennes étaient en
amélioration venait s'installer dans le
canada un peu partout et se sont
installés dans des endroits où il y
avait beaucoup de communes ou d'autres
comme moi je pense beaucoup communauté
crie de l'ouest en s'installant sur ces
territoires ont créé des relations
justement avec les premières nations qui
était présent et par les échanges par
les amitiés justement les tissus qui
sont arrivés dans les communautés dans
l'ouest ont vraiment été inspirés par
les gens qui les apportaient vaut bien
d'autres ont été cuits rire et perd la
jemaye le tissu devenir plus en plus
utilisées et quand je veux pas entrer
justement à peu le l'histoire de
l'immigration qui existe à travers le
canada mais je dis regardez les tissus
les tissus salue avec les personnes dont
on a adopté les tissus seulement les
relations qu'on a bâtie chez les i nous
par exemple nous c'est le plaid échos
c'est donc une grande vague
d'immigration écossaise qui est venu
chez nous mais aussi l'irlande être
parce qu'on peut voir aussi les petits
motifs fleuris qui venait avec les dames
irlandaise faut pas oublier que c'était
les femmes qui choisissent aime beaucoup
les tissus que les autres femmes
allaient choisir donc les femmes étaient
souvent au poste de traite la femme du
monsieur call est justement la tête
reposée 13-17 choisissez les dessus
d'ailleurs beaucoup de nos petits soucis
sont inspirés de ou ceux qui ont été
pris de ce qu'ils étaient venus avec les
par exemple les agendas gers et je pense
aux costumes traditionnels et nous
c'était vraiment une manière de voir
qu'ils vivaient avec qui sur le
territoire est bien le flao craignait
représente justement cette relation est
en ce moment vu le tac qui est vécu par
la nation ukrainienne sur son territoire
il ya beaucoup de communautés d'octobre
une personne dans la communauté veulent
faire sortir l'histoire derrière le
floor le coup comscore pour parler
justement de ce qui a été bâti et de la
solidarité parce qu'il faut savoir qu'on
comporte comme spurs beaucoup en respect
des aînés des ancêtres ça représente la
grand mère et un rôle extrêmement
important chez nous donc en pensant à
tous ceux qui vont affecter directement
et sans avoir eu aucun plan de décision
on pense aux gens main aux aînés on
pense aux femmes on parle aux enfants de
comstar manière de garder dans nos nous
penser dans nos prières justement la
nation
krainer de pouvoir être celle d'arrêter
avec des gens qui l'ont été avec nous
par le passé d'ailleurs on peut voir des
parts seront pas souvent d'appropriation
culturel mais là faut aussi voir les
moments d'adoption culturel et c'est
lorsqu'on parle de canots kayaks
raquette mais nous c'est elle est issue
ça a été les objets décoratifs le floral
et donc en l'honneur de la nation
ukrainienne aujourd'hui je voudrais
dédier ma chronique
j'aimerais aussi invité tous ceux qui
voient venir justement l'impact que des
conflits mondiaux à avoir sur non
seulement la visibilité des enjeux
autochtones sur le cycle médiatique mais
aussi comment on va avoir besoin de plus
en plus de ressources et que ces
ressources se trouvent souvent sur des
territoires autochtones est ce que la
pression qui vient d'un conflit européen
va avoir des impacts sur justement la
relation de canadiennes avec les
communautés autochtones ça va être à
voir donc n'hésitez pas avoir aidé des
questions n'hésitez pas nous aurons
plein de renvoyer des pistes dd com sur
des angles que vous ayez venir vous sur
les enjeux autochtones lien justement au
conflit européen
alors je vais vous souhaiter une très
belle semaine je vais rester en pensez
en prière avec les gens qui souffrent
présentement en grève et je pense que ça
va être un moment qu'on va se réveiller
beaucoup à ce qui se passe autour de
nous et des fois même très loin de nous
mais quand même plus proche qu'on pense
je vous souhaite une belle semaine